foreign
hi there my name is Psy and I'm the
director of product management here at
Google for user protection
and my name is Shelly I'm a product
manager at apogee working on API
security
Welcome to our talk on securing your
application against DDOS API abuse
hijacking and fraud
organizations must protect against many
types of attacks everything from Bots to
API abuse to fraud is hitting your
applications on a regular basis and the
factors of attack are multiplying
rapidly
in all of these areas the threats just
keep growing with the footprint of
applications on web and mobile
bot attacks are up 84 percent API abuse
impacts 50 of organization account
takeovers increasing by 90 percent and
fraud topping 24 billion dollars in the
United States alone
now we recognize the challenge of
putting together Point solutions to
solve for all of these evolving threats
so we here at Google have come together
to assemble a comprehensive solution to
prevent application Fraud and Abuse our
layered application defense consists of
cloud armor apogee and recapture
and together they can protect your
application from abuse and fraud no
matter where the traffic comes from or
where your applications are deployed
we have three layers to this defense
first Cloud armor defends against DDOS
attacks at the networking layer
second apogee defends against API abuse
and third recaptcha Enterprise defense
against sophisticated credential
stuffing atos and payments fraud on the
client now let me turn it over to
Shelley who can help us learn more about
Cloud armor and apogee
[Music]
thank you Sai now let me take you
through a short brief about Cloud armor
Cloud armor provides global scale
defense against volumetric protocol and
application attacks
it is built using the same technology
and infrastructure that Google uses to
protect its multi-billion user web apps
only in 2022 Cloud armor mitigated what
was then the largest distributed denial
of service attack in the world with no
impact to our customers
in addition to DDOS protection Cloud
armor also provides waft protection
focused on us top 10 for apps such as
SQL injection or cross-site scripting
users can also use cloud armor for
geofencing to define a loud or denied
regions countries or IPS
that way limiting the access to the
perimeter of the digital environment
lastly Cloud armor is part of gcp and is
highly embedded with the different
capabilities to allow logging monitoring
and alerting
going a bit deeper into Cloud armor on
this slide you can see the various
functionalities first thing is L3 L4
datus protection which is always on for
all projects using Global load balancers
it detects and mitigates network DDOS
attacks like scene floods or UDP
amplification attacks
we offer pre-configured waffles using
the mod security open source
we have a custom rule language where you
can create filtering policies to allow
deny redirect or rate limit connections
it's important to note that cloud armor
can be deployed in front of any website
or service to support hybrid or
multi-cloud architectures
for bot management Cloud armor acts as
an enforcement Point determined by
recapture models for fraud and Bot
detection engines for bot management
Cloud armor acts as an enforcement Point
determined by recapture models for fraud
and Bot detection engines
one of the more Innovative capabilities
we have is our layer 7 adaptive
protection ml based functionality
it is designed to detect volumetric
leaders attacks the system looks at
dozens of attributes about the
connections and how they relate to each
other
the ml models good traffic and then
notifies when highly suspicious patterns
are emerging
these models have been tuned over the
past five years on our web services and
now we are offering it as a feature to
our customers reducing time to detect
and mitigate
now let's move on to apigee and API
security
when we look at apis we see many
stakeholders users and interaction
points
we as security people also see a lot of
risk the end users of the apis are users
and many times it's the customers of our
customers
they could be the public or also
partners that consume services
usually apis are built and consumed by
applications like our bank app or
favorite coffee app
next there are the developers that read
those apps and connect the different
backend Services through the available
apis
most of our customers have API teams
that manage the API platforms and guide
the developers on best practices
and finally of course we have the data
that includes sensitive data in order to
control the risk one should have
security visibility and control to each
step in the process
it spans from threat protection that
includes abuse detection through Access
Control using oauth or API keys with SSO
management like IM integration
governance that includes role-based
Access Control masking compliance
requirements and lastly data security
with TLS requirements or encrypting
functionality
apogee offers many policies and services
to meet these requirements and general
API management use cases
we have a way to verify API Keys
generate and validate auth access tokens
apply to rate limiting or API schema
validation
we treat apis as the products that way
users can Define these products and
govern which consumers can access which
apis with quotas and permissions we
provide analytics on top of that so
users could understand how their apis
are being consumed
lastly is part of gcp we are integrated
into the wider platform and provide
identity and access management and Cloud
logging functionality
another way to look at apigee is by
having developer aimed services such as
monetization API catalog API products
and Marketplace
on the other hand we have Gateway
services such as security orchestrations
and transformations
while serving multiple runtime
environments such as multi-cloud SAS or
on-prem
and all of these are served with strong
analytics to monitor business kpis API
performance and different usage patterns
Advanced API security is an add-on on
top of apigee which is focused on
premium Security Services
it helps users design and build secure
apis
as being part of the API management
platform we are embedded in the entire
API life cycle and are able to provide
visibility and control to API security
configurations
operate securely means how do you secure
your apis in runtime
we detect any abuse on your API logic or
sensitive information and provide
in-product dashboards or integration
with SIM for further analysis and
alerting
lastly we bring to apigee the experience
we have in Google with security and
machine learning in order to improve
your security posture
how do we do that we are part of apigee
control plane we run on already existing
analytic data
this means that no additional data is
required so no new privacy concerns or
approvals are needed
we see how apis are configured and also
know what are the best practices and
right way to configure secure
environments
and we integrate seemingly into the
runtime to take action as an enforcement
point
this allows us to react with close to
zero latency impact on the API calls
we recently released new API abuse
detection dashboards powered by Machine
learning models trained to detect abuse
detection in real-time API traffic
the first two use cases we focused on
are scraping and anomaly detection
we also added clustering algorithm to
help reduce the noise and focus on the
most sensitive and timely incidents
we group The detected API calls in
clusters and give teams enough context
to quickly understand and act on them
now let's look at the demo
here we see the incidents in the last
two weeks we can also see the severity
level given by the system
jumping into the environment we can see
the list of incidents with more
information such as high level
description severity number of API calls
in the incidence time frame
let's look at one of the incidents more
closely
here we can get more context like the
API proxies that were targeted the
pattern across time the rules that were
triggered in the origin countries
for example here we see the advanced
scraper which is the new ml based Google
train detection rule
in case a security person wants more
info we have the attribute page that
gives more details such as the API
products
the client IDs that were part of the
incident
and the different IPS that triggered the
API calls
everything is built to help a security
expert or an API owner to understand
whether this is suspicious activity
triggered on their apis
[Music]
thanks Shelley many of you know
recaptcha from the visual challenges
either in text or images that you may
have had to click through in order to
access different web resources that is
the old recaptcha now more than 10 years
old in recent years we built a new
frictionless solution that installs on
JavaScript in order to provide users and
developers a completely frictionless
experience
this new version acts by analyzing the
behavior of users on the page that is
the captcha
not only is it harder for adversaries to
fool since the solution is
non-deterministic unlike a Turing test
but it is also frictionless for users
this enables developers to put recaptcha
everywhere on their site and mobile
applications to keep users safe with no
additional friction
with this expansion recapture Enterprise
is now available on 5 million sites
around the world this gives us
unparalleled visibility into legitimate
traffic as well as adversarial or
fraudulent traffic across the vast
majority of the internet
enabling our models to keep your web and
mobile applications safe while not
interrupting legitimate users
and this is really where a recapture
Enterprise becomes a total fraud
solution we can analyze data from all
traffic types web mobile and Waf
and we can detect all major types of
fraud ranging from fake accounts to
account takeovers to payments fraud and
one comprehensive fraud platform
next let me run you through three of our
biggest launches for the year that
really round out our total fraud
solution for Developers
our first launch is for mobile native
applications to provide our best
coverage on device we now offer native
Android and iOS sdks this ushers in a
new era of detection for recapture
Enterprise where we can integrate all of
the device signals seen by an
application into a fraud score in
addition to the usual behavior that
we've traditionally been able to see
we've also made this an easy install for
developers with the Android SDK
installed through Google's Maven
repository and the iOS SDK made
available via cocoapods package manager
or via direct download
and now you can see the in-app
instrumentation is small enough that we
can include it right here on the slide
making it just that easy to install as
the JavaScript version
account Defender is our second launch
that we are now able to bring to Market
this year traditionally recaptcha has
been installed as a web-based login
defense mechanism against credential
stuffing and account takeover
however we've expanded that to really
cover the entire hijacking or account
takeover risk workflow it starts by
observing users registration Behavior
and the subsequent login events for
anomalies then we can check the username
and password combinations against our
Global leak database to ensure they're
not compromised
we will then enable you to trigger
two-factor authentication with email or
SMS integration right in the recaptcha
platform
finally if you do observe any abuse we
offer the related accounts API to help
you find similar accounts to the ones
that you know are abusive
and our third launch that I'm truly
excited about is fraud prevention
we have expanded recaptcha to the final
frontier of the user experience and I'm
sure the most important for any site the
payments page
fraud prevention enables recapture to
combine transaction and behavior data on
site in order to Leverage The Best In
Class behavioral intelligence recaptcha
in concert with the payments instrument
data provided by traditional providers
we found this unique combination able to
capture and detect fraud that others
have missed as well as to lower friction
on legitimate users who may otherwise
have had transactions rejected
all right so let's move on with a live
example of what it looks like to install
and use recaptcha Enterprise on your
site
to get started all we really need is a
project name and a domain
type those in and then just click get
started
it's just that easy we've automated all
the typical provisioning processes that
will happen in the background for the
developer
when it's done you'll have a fully
provisioned project with the recaptcha
API enabled with 1 million calls a month
at your fingertips
now you are ready to go directly to the
cloud console
now we're in the cloud console we've
provided a demo embedded into recapture
Enterprise
so after you sign up you'll be able to
use it exactly as you see here today to
get started just select your preferred
language and it will automatically
deploy the project for you
this project is a live web application
it has a front-end demo website and
configuration of the back end to call
recaptch to score a user interaction
when it's ready just click view site
now let's take a look at the source code
on the front end we have the JavaScript
installation that monitors the user
interaction
and on the back end we can see how to
form the request to the recaptcha server
and that's really all there is to a
proper implementation of recapture
Enterprise
now that it's installed we can see what
it looks like running on a live site
this is a sample login site where a user
enters the username and password and
then clicks login
in the case of a legitimate user nothing
happens there's no need to solve a
challenge or add any additional friction
all that happens is that recaptcha
observes user behavior and relays a
score to you the developer to make a
decision on next steps
in the case of a fraudulent interaction
recapture will show you the low risk
score
and the reasons why we believe it to be
a risk
in this case we believe there's
automation happening on page
and this would be where you would
trigger two-factor authentication step
up or password leak Defender to check
this user for potential compromise
finally if you put recaptcha on a
payment page it can look at the payment
details in combination with the user
Behavior to make a judgment on the risk
of that transaction leading to a
chargeback or fraud in real time
when we enter the card number and click
buy now we can see the result to the
left
this is scored based on all the aspects
of the proposed transaction as well as
the on-page behavior
this demo site contains all the examples
you need to see how recapture can work
to protect your site from registration
to login to the payments page all with
no user friction
and now let's look at the console for
Analytics
you can see the current health of your
site and any attacks that are occurring
we have total number of requests and a
Time series graph of requests received
and down here we have a threshold
recommendation
now we know there's always a trade-off
between blocking bad users and adding
friction for good users
so recapture provides developers with
the flexibility to continually tune the
score thresholds on where to enforce
based on what's best for their
application and their users
developers can also simulate different
thresholds to see the impact on their
block rates
this will give developers a sense of
volume for malicious activity
the second graph here shows visual
capture challenges that are passed and
failed
alright in just four minutes we showed
you how to get recapture Enterprise
installed and protecting your web and
mobile applications from registration to
login to payments
and that concludes our three layers of
defense for web applications with Cloud
armor for DDOS apogee for API abuse and
recapture Enterprise for credential
stuffing atos and fraud
if you'd like to learn more you can use
the QR code on our screen to view our
application defense solution
thanks for watching
[Music]
foreign